greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by four hymns Dom a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care and sexual wellness
listen with age comes wisdom beginning
older girls don't be a downer in one
specific area if you know what I'm
talking about 40% of men by the age of
40 struggled from not being able to get
and maintain an erection
why do guys turn to weed solutions or
they don't do nothing at all
instead of going to doctors and getting
medicine and relating to science
expensive pills and injections
nobody wants a an injection but I'll
tell you what well-known generic
equivalents to name-brand prescriptions
to help you combat IDI that's what for
hems calm does answer a few questions
about your medical history chat with a
doctor for a confidential review if
you're approved by the doctor products
are shipped directly to your door nobody
knows nothing and if you're under 40 and
you want to go out to a party you want
to bring some extra ammunition for him
as their fee also so do me a favor the
church family right now this month I'm
gonna give you a month for hip four
hymns for five dollars you heard it
right five hours will get you started
with just five bucks while supplies last
prescription products are subject to
doctor approval and require an online
consultation with the physician who will
determine this prescription is
appropriate see the website for full
details and safety information but for
right now go to forums comm slash Church
that's for hems comm slash Church listen
the summer's here wiping your butt with
dry toilet paper does all God's nothing
it does not remove all this [ __ ] if you
got [ __ ] on any other part of your body
would you just wipe it off with dry
paper [ __ ] no water cleans [ __ ]
better than dry paper so thank God for
tushy tushy is a portable the day that
Clips right on to your toilet bowl no
plumber no nothing it clips to your
existing toilet and sprays your butt
completely [ __ ] clean
with fresh water that toilet water
that's memory used and somebody else
wash their ass with it no fresh [ __ ]
water it's called pushy and it's the
best thing you could do for your little
stinky [ __ ] muffler right till she
sprays directly into your ass and
removes this [ __ ] so you aren't sitting
on bacteria that leads to nasty things
like hemorrhoids yeast infections UTI
itchy ass holes skid marks and God knows
what the [ __ ] house you understand me
what do you think when a chick sucks
your pipe she doesn't smell that [ __ ]
Newark yeah for an [ __ ] you gotta
wash that ass
it's the summertime and you're living in
the humidity uncle Joey's here to help
you go to hello Toshi calm slash Church
listen to me hello tushy calm slash
Church it's that easy get 10% off your
order right go - hello - she calm slash
Church Lisa at check this [ __ ]
meal Andrew what's this go another day I
love that
that's the jammin I love how I kick in
with that it really is that's the
jamming a decade years ago when you
asked me Jared a century ago we're all
gonna come out with I said it was like
instant I didn't have but there was no
thought yeah I don't know how lovely
[ __ ] brakes that's it yeah I do love
it I do love it great to have you on the
show you great spin on it and beautiful
thank you congratulations on a star is
born now here's the [ __ ] crazy thing a
lot of people don't know I know this
because we had snicker how long to
sitting there oh okay you also want to
do the guest book so anyway the green
book the green book yeah gas book the
green book anyway you call it you're
gonna either be in one Academy
award-nominated film or [ __ ] tool well
you know what honestly I was really
happy for Nick because you know just
like us the guy struggled and struggled
and I know all about the movie and what
the movie was about about his dad and
like he couldn't even believe like when
it was gonna get made you know what I
mean like when there was a deal falling
into place and then all of a sudden
Spielberg signed on you know I would
took all the Amblin
my company you know and Nick's coming to
me going you know Spielberg's now
producing this like I was just thrilled
for him because this is a guy just like
us you know did whatever you had to do
to pay his rent you know and you know
now he's he's the winner
not just the Best Picture the Best
Screenplay and he's just cooking now as
a matter of fact he was talking about
you cuz she both did the soprano spur
yes yes how was that great he was great
he's like the greatest guy right
sweetheart of a man you know just a
sweetheart I'm a me shot a film with him
in 2012 oh okay so you know that's how
we met and he was explaining his the
story to me about his father blah blah
blah until this day I've always said any
mob moved over the scene his father's
got the best line any morning opening of
the Pope of Greenwich Village
Mickey Rourke walks into a restaurant
and the maitre d says to him or the way
that goes the guy wants to talk to you
in the back that's how the movie opens
it's still rolling he goes into the
bathroom and there's a guy shaking his
dick Rip's a paper off the thing and he
goes oh how come nobody keeps me wait
when they look in the blahblah it
[ __ ] just just threw me off that's
like our movie you know somebody wants
to borrow money they're there ten
minutes before like not let me a pulp is
like a Bible to us you know I'm finally
lost my [ __ ] mind but it's a now
talking to you about the film if Ava
don't cook make his first line Charlie
I'm coming I'm coming Charlie well he
says to him I have to like cut his thumb
off and he's in the room with the
punching bag and I haven't done this in
a long time and he's all stoned out from
taking all the pills cuz Mickey's going
how many you knows I don't know I took I
don't [ __ ] and then he's like hitting
the the the there's a heavy bag and
Mickey's telling him how his girlfriend
dumped him you know and Eric Roberts
character is like what's his name again
in the movie Eric Roberts Charlie
Charlie
volley boy uh-huh sometimes you gotta
smack em you know you gotta say you put
your coat on and you don't say goodnight
tongue no body and that's just a humble
little you know and then he passes out
for long you know let me you don't smack
no kanakam I What did he say you know he
goes sometimes you got us back no no you
swagger and say you put yeah it's not
about knocking him out it's just your
clothes got a good night you put your
coat on and you don't say good night
Todd no body and that's just a humble mo
you don't hit him my gear in the old
country give him a little whack he said
something right yeah well I don't have
the exact script in front of me I'm
sorry
35 years ago Wow so nobody's got the
right script in front of ya five [ __ ]
years you've showed me the clip of that
now I have seems very close I have been
waiting for the sequel for that there's
equal they had it and it's so funny
because the guy that was like a PA on
that movie was the producer on
spider-man 2 did what you know and I
went up to him he shook his hand he's
like how did you even see that you know
who the original kiss was supposed to be
Pope no it was supposed to be Pacino and
James Caan that's it was gonna do that
movie and what happened they fell out
and Mickey in and Eric Roberts did it
and that's the only way I could ever see
that movie now like even when I think of
how great Pacino and James Caan I'm sure
they would have done but you just see
the scene like we're doing the scenes
from the movie there's so many great
lines in that movie when they're at the
[ __ ] horse table ah
and then milking or whatever the [ __ ]
they're doing the foot in the yours uh
it's like your mother's mutts around not
for nothing but I went to your mother
store Lester's tough what's around yeah
and the guy gets any cats not yes the
Caputo's have never made a parody
somewhat - laughs yeah
not but nothing but your mother's
mozzarella is a kind of tough it was
kind of tough I used to do all that on
stone impressions he cut his thumb off
with a knife Frankie Vince's uh-huh I
love Frank I got to work with Frank
Vincent I was in 1884 you sit there and
you know what the [ __ ] happened all
these years I was a good [ __ ] if
movies no but he he Frankton a ton of
movies Frank was amazing amazing you
know you know you know he was supposed
to be Scorsese was looking at him for
when they were doing the Raging Bull
okay
and so they were looking at a film like
a b-movie with Frank Vincent
and in the background was Pesci
you know like doing something on stage
because him and Frank were partners like
a comedy team and and Scorsese was like
who's that guy then they both obviously
wound up in the movie but it made
Pesci's career because he wasn't even
being thought of at the time from what I
know from the stories I've been told so
they both wound up becoming these
big-time actors he put him with
everything Frankie Vincent except I
think mean streets yeah is Frank you've
been said no no this is all this is all
post-post mean streets you know this was
once it became like Raging Bull time no
I
what was it or was it good foot
whichever one came first Raging okay
okay and then good phone and he was like
a restaurant waiter or something Joe
Pesci manager at a restaurant and him
and Frank he was a drummer yeah Frankie
Vincent was a drummer or something and
they won't like him some we had like a
little drum battle yeah you crack a joke
and I hit the cymbal yeah but they were
team they were team yeah that's what I
heard but we did we did this movie that
never came out me and Frank Vincent we
did Linux top of Mexico what's called
the good life was this crazy thing that
we went through in Mexico for like two
months but there was a set of drums so
we were going back and forth he was a
good drummer he was like a real jazz
drummer
yeah great guy just
a great guy like he's the way you would
have wanted him to be when you meet him
you know he didn't play the you know
when I'm not on screen I'm this quiet
[ __ ]
like some of these actors are you know
he's dead personality Pesci the greatest
you know all these guys I when I first
met you you were just getting off the
set
oh well we would still own this brother
that's the movie the good life and you
were playing golf or something like that
yeah you toured the movie never came out
you tortured the brother - no way
because it wasn't being a team player
you want to torture Frank if I get into
that story we will not get to talk about
anything else and I love no no Frank
give me one torture chamber you put the
feeling okay you know my world Frank
aided rap music okay no but Frank
happens to be like a great great singer
like he's got that Sinatra style of
singing like he can do that with the big
band okay and but I didn't know too much
of it back then all right so anyway
Frank would go off and piss all over
Harry Connick who was the biggest at the
time with the big band stuff okay and so
me and Frank would argue over this and
I'm saying how great Connick is you know
and Frank would piss all over it and one
day in the makeup trailer at this this
actor Peter Dobson was also doing the
movie with us so I loved entertaining
Dobson by fighting with Frank all day or
night you know and the reason the
fighting would happen would be because
he wasn't being a team player with us
like Frank would be like do you
understand this movie's my [ __ ] shot
you know and I'm the lead in this movie
and then he'd leave my room and I'd look
at Peter Dobson ago I'm gonna turn this
movie into a [ __ ] Jerry Lewis movie
movie was supposed to be followed the
kind of movie this is supposed to be
Goodfellas on a golf course
okay okay it's a very
tough moving you know and I'm behind
Frank to an impersonation of him smoking
he doesn't even see me doing [ __ ] I'm
mocking him on screen because of the way
he treated us okay so now he's with the
Connick [ __ ] so one day I come into
to make up this is in it's 110 degrees
in Ixtapa Mexico been to Ixtapa no
nobody has you understand there's
nothing there
I didn't eat food for five weeks
everybody was winding up in the [ __ ]
Hospital Don Barris broke is like ankle
in a hole in the floor or something so
every day I would eat at 5 o'clock I
would have pasta and garlic bread and
coke with purified ice and I would eat
til the next day at the same time that's
all I would eat because everybody was
falling at the waist and going to the
hospital but it was a beautiful island
in Mexico ok so I come in to make up and
Frank's there and he's blasting that
it's distorted his his cassette tape ok
of his music that's how loud he was
playing it and I don't say a [ __ ]
word because you know when I have a
thing about me and I really made it like
a big thing when I did Entourage about
nobody [ __ ] with dice dice does the
[ __ ] in the long run for always and
forever dice does the [ __ ] that's
just the way it is I don't care if it's
an executive a showrunner or an actor
whoever wants to [ __ ] with me learns
that in the end I will do the [ __ ]
that's it it's how I've lived my life so
I'm letting the music just blast and
Peter's there and he's not saying
nothing I'm doing my hair and makeup and
so now when I'm done with the makeup
you know Frank's still sitting there and
Peter's still sitting there and as I'm
passing the the distorted cassette
player
I lowered the volume okay a go
you know something Frank you know I'm
gonna say it and I'll say in front of
this whole trailer full of people you do
sing better than Harry Connick jr. I go
the difference is Harry Connick jr.
sings the songs people want to hear
and that's why he did nine nights at
Madison Square Garden and I cranked the
music and walking [ __ ] you he's trying
to yell at me and I just walked the [ __ ]
out you know it's like come on but Frank
really does in all honesty
he's like an unbelievable crooner well
kidding aside would a 16-piece orchestra
this guy swings like Sinatra you know
and I even have him on like all my
playlists like you know how you make
playlists on your iPod or that and I
would call this [ __ ] [ __ ] and I go
did you know once we became friends
again it only took like three years
after the movie and I go Frank why are
you not in Las Vegas with the orchestra
just swinging five nights a week
well dice if you got me an agent why the
[ __ ] do I need to get you an agent I got
your ass Stallone your slides brother he
can't get you a personal appearance
agent you wanted the best they go and I
love like Michael Buble I love all these
guys but he sings better Frank is better
he's just a better singer you know you
either feel something when you perform
me you don't you know and he's one of
those guys when he gets on stage he just
feels it you know and then he'll pick up
the acoustic guitar go no not the
acoustic who gives a [ __ ] about you with
an acoustic guitar swing [ __ ]
just [ __ ] swing he's amazing he
really is amazing
he put a damn mop maybe 12 years ago I
used to work on at this gym and they
threw the cassette out the [ __ ] DVD I
you know whatever he walked him they put
rap music yeah now he's actually a great
guy he reads like a
book a day like you know but you know
and that you know that movie never came
out there was a lot of problems and
Dennis Hopper was in the movie you know
sly was in the movie they did it he did
a cameo you know and um you know I it
just became a mess and you know I you
know I had like a so what nothing
not what happened I get a call there's a
long time ago so I guess I could select
30 is it so I you know I get a call I'm
sitting at the pool with my you know
wife at the time I got a whisper this
and uh so now I get a call like from
slice attorney that there's a problem
and there might be a big lawsuit with
the movie so I'm trying to tell the
attorney like well you know if there's a
problem you know call me whatever like
I'm blowing it off because you know it
was like a little indiscretion with me
and like one of the producers like a
little like look a little onset affair
it was an accident you know and uh you
know so I couldn't be sitting on the
phone next to the woman I love going I
can't talk about it now because you know
there was a thing with the producer you
know but if you need me I'm with you you
know it's crazy what would go on I did
you know I'm not [ __ ] good I just
can't help myself I left but the
marriage didn't work out I don't believe
I'm cheating on your wife but if you
bump into a [ __ ] so I didn't told you
walking down this I don't look it is
like why and blow do you ever look at it
like cheating being bird that just comes
down and suck your dick and flies and no
but how does this sound Joey it's not
cheating if you're in another state and
your wife can't get there in time
you know like I've called different
wives and girlfriends and go listen I
will wait till midnight to blow my cork
but you gotta be there and be ready to
catch it you know or else I got no
choice you leave me no choice
you know I'm nice like that I don't want
to cheat on them you know what I mean
they do it to themselves you know how
are you gonna get from across the
country I got a load that's boiling in
my balls you know what I mean I know I
got a complete face full of paste for
you you know what I mean so where are
you then where are you with your [ __ ]
holder you know and your mouth wait a
[ __ ] are you you know what I mean you
know cuz I'm a guy I really do enjoy sex
I you know it's the reason I date you
know you know I I don't mind blowing my
own load but you know I'd rather have
somebody there yeah that if I'm bored
with myself alright come over here don't
be shy you know what I mean move two
pillows out from between us I do hate
sharing a bedroom with a girl oh yeah
you know I mean and trust me I'm not
doing any like stage material here I'm
not showcasing foot whoever's listening
this is just who I am but like you know
like let's say you have an argument like
with your chick okay what do you do you
turn you back to her right always you
know like like that's gonna stop you
know all of a sudden she opens up the
laptop with the glow like like a UFO it
just landed in the [ __ ] bedroom so
you're not gonna be able to sleep but if
you have your own bedroom and not
everybody could afford it you know but
if you have enough bedrooms it's like
have your own [ __ ] bedroom so when
you do have an argument you just go over
there you know instead of being in the
same room and hearing the heavy
breathing are you really gonna be like
walk out of the room just walk out of
the room I don't get away your sleep you
know what I mean so it's very hard to
share a bedroom you know that's what I
believe in I don't even
we're talking about this stuff goes too
far because I was no [ __ ] good you
know I tell my sons all the time my god
you know I'm you know a smoker you know
which I quit now you know I'm a gambler
you know I you know I would I cheat on
all my girls you know because you know
because they just don't allow you to
bang all the chicks without any
repercussion you know I just never
understood that that you know the whole
Mormon thing always throw me off going
so why could some jerk-off guy living in
[ __ ] Utah be able to [ __ ] ten chicks
and take a pic this one for tonight or
this enough you know and I'm the nicest
guy in the world and I get one and then
all of a sudden you know cuz I'm not the
guy that bangs on that time at a month I
could live without at that time in a
month but give me like a little room
right you know you know let me go have a
few laughs I I didn't create this cycle
that you go through and now today you
know how they all want you to really
understand what they what a [ __ ] is what
you go through I'm not a girl I'm never
gonna understand this [ __ ] just tell me
when I could hop the [ __ ] back on that's
all I want to know yeah you know like if
I start dating a girl I like a score
like I know when that kind time in a
month like like do you really get like
in a bad mood like one to ten like you
know like give me the answers to the
test that I need to know if I could make
this a serious relationship you know
like between one and ten how bad is it
do you go seven days is it a three day
like quickie you know because I'm not
waiting seven [ __ ] days and watching
you angry for seven days there's no way
I'm living with you if that's the
[ __ ] thing you know just live on your
own and come see me when you wait when
you're available to do whatever I need
done are you done with marriage now um
are you writing it off um you know I
should never say done you know what I
mean like I'm not looking for it because
you know I would like to now
you know it's like two years since me
and my ex broke up so it's time like you
know I I like having somebody but number
one she's got to be hot as balls you
know what I mean that's you know I'm not
gonna settle for anything less you know
I mean why go with something that looks
like [ __ ] livestock you know what I
mean I'm in [ __ ] show business I'm
dice so you know you know I want to be
picky about who the next one is and but
marriage I don't know maybe you know I
would marry like maybe I don't know like
a like something different like eating
somebody number one wealthier than me
you know a name bike a 22 year old
Chinese it's not even about the age just
have a lot more money than me
like if I met like an armless
billionaire beautiful there's something
I haven't been with you know what I mean
like like she won't have to turn her car
like with her teeth you know what I mean
like you know I mean to make the illegal
u-turns that would be different but
realize you know if I meant like like
all the girls I've ever married you know
and I've been a ton of them and
engagements and all kinds of [ __ ] and um
but I would actually I I got a thing
like I actually need to really be crazy
about the girl I married because you
know like when you meet these women
they're looking for a guy like with a
lot of money and they spend their life
like looking you know to collect
diamonds and cause and money it's like
you're wasting your time on earth being
with somebody you're not even really
into yeah you know what I mean we're
most of the woman from LA or was it it's
women from anywhere like you know a lot
of mothers do teach Decker oh it's just
as easy to marry rich isn't it how about
marrying just what you love you know I
mean cause any girl I ever married I was
in love with that's it
until I hated them you know till it fell
apart
you know cause it's Joey even knows my
relationships have been like I was with
my son's mom for 16 years that's a
that's a long run yeah you know even my
last relationship was nine years that
that's a long run you know
yeah I never went you know with a girl
for her money
you know like yet when I came out here I
was dating sandy sure for a little while
Mitsy was like oh you'll marry my
daughter there's 21 [ __ ] years old you
know and you know forget about Jewish
girls you know yeah cuz my first girl
was the girl was a Jewish girl and she
just wrecked it for all the other Jewish
girls just awful to be with we get an
argument if I would look at a girl in
another car okay under $69 and we're
driving down Kings Highway in Brooklyn
she'd open the door to throw herself out
in the [ __ ] car but I'd have to grab
what the [ __ ] is right this was not a
one-time event
okay this went on at least once a week
where she's throwing herself out at a
car a moving car and um so one night I
asked her to marry me
you know look I wanted a guarantee
getting blown it was New Year's Eve
right and so she goes let's go tell my
parents whatever so I go it's 2:00 in
the morning we don't have that you know
let's do this instead you know cuz now
you're gonna be married and now let's go
so we go wake the parents up and we're
sitting there and I actually read did
this in my first special Diceman cometh
right where this girl calls me she goes
what's he ever gonna be he's like a
nothing that's how this girl would act
because her father I don't want to name
names or anything but her father at that
time was a top NBA ref in the country
and back then referees was famous as the
players you know and I don't even follow
sports but he was like if you heard his
name it was like [ __ ] you know yeah and
the guy made like fifty grand a year and
you know all the perks whatever so we
wake the parents we're gonna get married
and she starts him with me it's 3:00 in
the morning
about the ring now I'm working in a
clothing store bringing home like 200 a
week and I'm you know I wasn't thinking
this far I wanted to blow job you know
what I mean I'm not thinking about
spending 30 grand on a ray
you know and she goes what do you mean
you're not gonna get me I go I can't
afford an expensive ring right now and
she starts a fight in front of her
parents
and all of a sudden you know I'm an
explosive personality so I'm just like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] ha I'm yelling at the
parents I go you keep this no-good
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm out of this
relationship and I go to leave the
apartment which had a bunch of steps
leading to the front door that she's now
wrapped her arms around my neck
and letting defeat drag on the steps and
I'm screaming at a father
get this [ __ ] animal off of me before
she gets [ __ ] hurt and the fathers
[ __ ] pulling her off for me you know
and I'm like it's 3:00 in the morning
this is 3:00 in the [ __ ] morning
Happy New Year Andrew happy [ __ ] New
Year you know and you know so after I
went with that girl I swore off like
Jewish girls and uh on my way to LA
first it was San Diego where my sister
lives and that's where I met sandy was
she was a great chick you know and uh I
guess she liked my attitude because you
know I knew I was in comedy for six
months I don't know about sports
I don't know about I was headlining pips
after my audition on Wednesday night I
was headlining Friday sadly you know
because I had an act where turned from
Jerry Lewis and to John Travolta from
grease so it would just kill so when I
come into the comedy store because my
sister goes oh there's a comedy store in
in in La Jolla you know and I go yeah
but what if the one in LA swear she goes
no I think they're connected like you
know psycho over there and remember John
the bartender yes okay so at state time
so I come over to this guy and I go yeah
I'd like to uh where do I sign up I want
to go on tonight you know I just came
from Tahoe and Vegas you know I was
performing there you know it was a sandy
Hackett thing and you know I made it
like it was a gig but it was just a
showcase and he goes oh you can't just
sign up you know you got a you got to
talk to the manager
and I go well where is it he goes now
it's a it's a she she's in her office
knock on the door you know beat be nice
with her you know like yeah okay you
know like I'm not even thinking Mitzie
comedy stick you know it means nothing
to me you know so it's sandy and yeah
can I help you I go yeah where do I sign
up for tonight you know she goes what do
you mean where do you sign up you know
it doesn't it doesn't work like I got
honey you know I just did Vegas just the
Tahoe you know I want to go on like what
are we gonna do and she liked me
immediately you know cuz like I was
might as well been from another planet
because I was from Brooklyn and I never
went I never left Brooklyn till I came
out here and she goes well why don't you
come back tonight about nine o'clock and
I'll get you on and I and I went on and
dazzled her and next thing you know
we're in her that she had this great
Riviera and next thing you know walking
the beach and you know where they keep
the condos and you know and then I come
to LA and I showcase from it's yeah did
28 minutes which the emcee you know rob
Aguayo do you remember how he was an
emcee back then but I don't know who's
the boss was the owner I just went on
and I did my whole act I give a [ __ ]
with the three minutes and this guy
starts screaming at me as I'm leaving
the stage and I know are you the owner
and he goes no but I'll make sure you
know get out of my way you know unless
the owner tells him I go I didn't come
3,000 miles to do three minutes okay so
move out of my way I'm warning you
you know and then I'm in the bathroom
like taking like putting all my Jerry
Louis stuff back in the bag and that's a
guy next to me this is my first
experience here and uh how you doing you
know you know in the regular bathroom in
the original room yeah good you know oh
you know me and you we sort of wear our
hair the same way you know because I
have a lot more hair back there like oh
yeah you know great you know
I help you with something because I
don't do that you know
you know he was like coming on to me and
who was it [ __ ] with me
Garry Shandling so I met Garry Shandling
and he started laughing I am Gary okay
goodbye and uh and then the next day I
get a call I was staying with my friend
in Alhambra where I just banging this
other chick on the couch that he set up
for me to his wife and I I get a call
you got to come to the comedy store and
sign papers you're a paid regular you
know and I didn't even know what that
all meant I just it was Mitchell Walters
that kept calling my father in Brooklyn
he he saw me at pips in Brooklyn he was
one of Mitzi's main guys you know
Mitchell yes so when he saw the act I
was doing he kept calling my father at
his office going you don't understand I
have prepped mitzi your son needs to
come out here and that's the reason I
even came to LA was close to Mitchell
you know and you know cuz he did a whole
number but he kept calling my father
till I finally said you know what let me
go out for two weeks and I didn't go
back to Brooklyn for nine months you
know for the first visit you know cuz
mitzi was like you you can't go back
there you know yeah you're a star what
you is this
it was 79 February 79 s when I came out
here yeah I started September 13 78 at
pips in Brooklyn so like you know half a
year later I'm in LA so I don't know
there's a comedy boom starting to happen
I just figured uh you know I'll go to LA
and just become like one of the biggest
stars in the world
what do I give a [ __ ] I got it I have no
academic skills so this is what I am
it's just I just project myself to the
[ __ ] also from a 79 to 87 what was going
on um I just well I did the Travolta act
till I did the Don Kirshner rock concert
which I did the Jerry Louis the Travolta
and i ended with stallone it was amazing
how we got away with using all that
music you know just nickel for you know
the rocky theme and
Rhys and all the music I used because
the producer was Tom Lynch who was 23
years old and I go don't we have to pay
like to use he goes - don't worry but
just do you rack and he wound up
producing my first special Diceman
cometh and yeah because I took off in it
was September 13th ok exactly 10 years
later February 13th
88 is when I add on the Rodney special
on a Saturday and Monday I was the
biggest comic in the world you know
that's what came first - Rodney special
or the advice mate no Rodney special I
never even really even needed my own
special because before my special hey I
was in arenas already it was ridiculous
no [ __ ] and and what I did I predicted
and I picked this up on my Instagram
where I put the ad on my Instagram of I
took a full-page ad in variety you know
on a Thursday the special was gonna add
the Saturday the 13th the Rodney thing
so on the 11th because you know Friday
how everybody closes down in show
business
so I took a full-page I spent about 3500
bucks on a full page half the page is my
picture a real attitude picture not even
in a leather I'm just sitting on a chair
backwards and the other side I wrote
this whole long poem about I like in
bold letters I never studied much in
school but when I turned on the tube and
then I listed everybody like there was
Elvis the King Buddy Rich with hands
like lightning Travolta sang and danced
sly knocked me out Brando made me pal I
mention all these heroes of mine and at
the end I write Murphy and Pryor both
great no doubt but in 88
it's dice they'll shout I never studied
much in school
dot-dot-dot but I did study
with big bull riding rodney dangerfield
nothing goes right saturday and i
predicted what it was going to be to the
entire industry and it's exactly how it
came down because number one rodney let
me edit my shot because he showed me an
edit of my you know what i did and i
looked at him and I'm like that's not
yeah he goes okay man why don't you work
on it alright
work on it with the director and I
worked on it for a couple hours I show
it to Rodney he goes you happy now man
okay all right
and that's what he let air because I
knew what was going to affect the public
you know I just you know I didn't care
what any of the comics we're gonna do on
that show I couldn't kill her what's his
name Barry soul ball shows up and what's
very sellable known for where leather
jacket no there's something baseball
jacket baseball Jack okay so he shows up
in a motorcycle jacket that they're all
trying to [ __ ] throw me off you know
all these [ __ ] guys so I go over to
Rodney and I go what's with Sobel and he
goes what do you mean man yeah cuz
Rodney looked at me like I'm gonna be
the guy you know that's it
like he knew that guy was gonna blow up
if I did the right set and I go why is
he in a motorcycle jacket that's not
what he wears hey Barry
come here a minute man you know
embarrass I get Ronnie goes what's with
the jacket you know goes where's the
baseball jacket he goes now I'm gonna
wear this he goes well you could wear it
but it's not gonna be on TV okay man so
go get your baseball jacket dice where's
the leather jacket you know and that was
it you know and I came up there we did
two shows on two different nights in the
first show and I left the stage I came
over to my father and my mother and
Trini you know and I said done biggest
comic in the world I didn't give a [ __ ]
about the cameras I played to America
that's how you got to do it you know all
the other comics worried about what
everybody else is doing all I cared
about I was so [ __ ] prepared
you know I would see these guys [ __ ]
around at the Comedy Store you know the
late-night crowds with three people and
they're [ __ ] around
you know Chimel I rewrite they're just
[ __ ] around on like you dumb [ __ ]
man when you get the shot of a lifetime
in front of you I don't care if there's
nobody in the room I'm running the set
you know and that's it because the one
thing I know is when you do a shot like
that you're gonna be a little nervous so
at least be prepared at least know
what's coming out of your mouth no
you're not gonna [ __ ] it up you know and
Rodney to this day you know without him
I wouldn't never happened you know the
greatest and let me do exactly what I
wanted to do and edit it exactly the way
I wanted to edit it and the rest became
history yeah how far so you didn't shoot
dice man coming for about a year and a
half no it it had nine months later you
know on New Year's Eve eight sort of
Rodney thing it's a February 13th 88 so
we're going into 89 so the Diceman
cometh add New Year's Eve 89 going into
90 at midnight you sure wasn't before
that yeah because it's nine months after
the Rodney special cuz I got walked up
in 88 yeah but that's when I hit I got
locked up I think that the roommate
showed me the [ __ ] the special
probably sort of rod anything because
that add New Year's Eve and then I got
out a February of 89 okay after the
Rodney's but after my special ad Iceman
Cometh okay so which ad New Year's Eve
going into into the next year New Year's
Eve 89 90 I rent it out the conference
room at the halfway out haha
and I put your special I know you would
tell me this that got food and people
couldn't believe it they were blown away
they tell
you guys get ready for this [ __ ] no it
was how on IMDb says January 1st 1989
something which means midnight right
right so yeah I think 80 yes so not 80
88 going to 89 not 89 going into that
idea I think right I saw it 89 going
into 90 okay yeah that's that's when it
was that's crazy because February we're
gonna sit here like three dummies trying
to figure out a date I say so if the
Rodney thing at February 13 88 right yes
so it makes sense
88 going into 89 right yet nine months
later
so you knew like were you having bad set
to that point like if you had not done
well do you think you would have known
or D or or do you it was that set just
something so special they you're like
okay I know that that's gonna kick ass
the this said on on Ronny like you know
I I was prepared you know I I remember
you know I was so prepared from
everything from the material to what I
was wearing the belt book was this
[ __ ] big you know it was ridiculous
and I walked from the Regency Hotel to
Rodney Dangerfield's Club like I told
Trini I go I got a feel the street you
know and as I'm walking you can imagine
people looking at this guy that looked
like a superhero walking the streets
with the belt buckle and the leather and
the glasses it was a whole thing and I
come into the club and Rodney stand in
there and he goes how do you feel man
you ready and I'm wearing these dark
glasses and I go tonight they pay
tonight they get disciplined and he just
starts laughing his ass off go okay man
tonight they're gonna pay all right man
you got some issues you know the way he
would you know he just loved how dead
serious I was like I couldn't give a
[ __ ] who was doing that show you know
the first thing is Joey showed me like
eight years ago sort of working together
it's it's the world of comedy see
there's you know back then like you know
nobody got behind me at all you know
when I went through the controversy with
the news and all that and journalists
and they were just coming down on me
every comic and his mother was on
[ __ ] television shows that weren't
even real shows like they were creating
morning shows just to talk about this
comic that shouldn't even be allowed to
perform okay so I had [ __ ] nobody
behind me which leads me to the to the
Roseanne thing you know and I was like
so I was never one of the pack you know
what I mean when George slaughter did
the The Comedy Awards for instance you
know the first year they were doing the
Comedy Awards I think that was 1990 and
you know who Tim Jones was right he
passed away recently black kid ya know
he did a little while ago yeah great guy
you know and we always liked each other
but we never had much to say to each
other we drive to La Jolla together and
Tim would always look at me and goes
we're just to talk about [ __ ]
you know cuz we wouldn't say a word but
we just liked each other
what did he die for if you don't know I
don't know I don't know what a
sweetheart you know he's a great guy I
mean I haven't seen him since the day I
haven't seen him in ten years but I'll
tell you we both had a pretty bad drug
problem no he's just a nice guy man nice
guy and this guy comes over to me so
it's the night of it's the year 2000
okay and they're doing the Comedy Awards
which I wasn't invited to I was never
invited to anything and I didn't know
they're having the party for The Comedy
Awards at the Comedy Store like if that
the after-party so I'm seeing all these
limos pull up because I said to Trini I
just want to get out you know I'll go to
the Comedy Store cuz it bothered me you
know and here comes Tim Jones over to me
at the Comedy Store and it goes why
weren't you at the Comedy Awards ago
wasn't invited and he goes that's unreal
to me he goes how don't they give an
award
to a guy that has sold more tickets than
any comic ever from the day the first
joke was told and they didn't give you
an award for that because I was doing 80
thousand people a week it was ridiculous
and I had to leave the store when I saw
that George Florida because that's what
I wanted to do I want the [ __ ]
slaughter to him you know and I came
home that night this is this is kind of
funny well it's not funny it's it you
know I'm actually meeting with these
people tonight they want to do like the
dice biopic you know and there's a lot
of drama in it obviously you know and
it's these guys that did a straight out
of Compton
you know so so I'm looking around I'm
sitting around this room that and in the
house I had a house in Beverly Hills so
we called the daddies den where I could
smoke my cigarettes and make my phone
calls to all hours of the night and it's
just bugging the [ __ ] out of me
you know all of it no matter how big I
was as a comic it's just bothering me
and I go inside and I sit on the bed and
I guess Trini felt me sit on the bed and
she goes are you were right how was he
that was just set and I'm just sitting
there and I go I'm going back to the
garden like oh these boys aren't gonna
grow up without seeing that and that's
it and she goes all right why don't you
just you know lay down whatever happened
you'll tell me tomorrow and what wound
up happening to go back to the garden
this is in 2000 I needed something
because I had no heat you know I was
living off my past Fame but as far as
like I was done I was blackballed from
the movie industry
the only kind of movies I could do with
like B movies you know and um you know
which may be one of them we'll talk
about brain smash it with Teri Hatcher
that was a special movie and so I get a
III I get a record deal just to have
something to promote you know
and and I got the deal like in two weeks
through this producer and so we put the
the record out and at that time I was
doing Opie and Anthony when they were on
FM like on the same station astern but
in the afternoon and since I wasn't
talking to start at the time I would
just do their show okay so my agent
calls me up and he goes alright the
reckoner he is off the shelves you know
what's the move like we would always
strategize I go book the garden and he
goes you want to book the garden he goes
last time you went Westbury you did half
a house meaning 1,500 people and now I'm
telling him to book you know 18,000 like
what's going on he thought I'm losing it
he goes why don't we do the beacon and
if the beacon sells out you know which
he didn't think it was you know that it
would take months to sell it out because
we could move the shoulder to God and so
I said Denis ago the beacons gonna sell
out in 20 minutes
I go you don't understand I'm doing this
radio show because so you do he goes
well why the garden like what's on put I
go because my sons who would 6 and 10 at
the time need to see that because it'll
do something for them you know in the
long run it's how I thought about it
like something will go in there you know
like we all looked at our own fathers in
whatever way and it goes so you want me
to call rondelle's name book Madison
Square Garden because you need a
photo-op with your sons echo court
whatever you want I go but it'll sell
out there's no problem because you're on
afternoon Drive I I don't get it you
know so we booked the beacon like he
says and everybody's taking bets on Opie
and Anthony how long it'll take I'm
saying 20 minutes it sold out in 35
minutes Beacon Theatre which was at that
time was 3300 seats so now I call my
agent and he don't know what to say
because she can't move the show The
Beacon owns the shoe yeah so he calls
rondelle's 'no
and so now the the beacon is gonna be
October 20th mm so he close up rondell's
'no and Dells 'no who is a legendary
promoter which we all know says look
obviously dice knows something we don't
he feels something we let's put 10,000
seats on sale at the garden look how
fast he sold the beacon but the only
available date was the following
Saturday which is the 26 now of October
first day on sale we do over 7,000
tickets which is ridiculous you know but
then it gets announced that the Mets are
gonna play the Yankees and I'm not even
into sports but I know how big a Subway
Series is gonna be the bottom line is I
get a call the day of the Garden which
you know Trinis they're my sons are
they're you know they're gonna see this
now you know so Dells it's rondelle's
'no and it goes would you mind if we
open up the back he goes were clean you
did the sellout you know so we did the
last night of the World Series the Mets
playing the Yankees we did over 14,000
people at the garden and my boys got to
see it and now they're rockin and rollin
okay so where I was gone with this whole
thing was about you know how even back
then just nobody ever stood the only one
that ever stood up for me was Eddie
Murphy you know he did come you know one
time he came out on Arsenio and talked
about how he doesn't give a [ __ ] what
anybody thinks he's coming to see me at
the amphitheater and um but other than
that all you know the Jay Leno's these
[ __ ] jerk-offs let him in nobody
backed me up you know that bad-mouthing
me I remember coming over to Leno when
he said something nasty about me and I
just came out in an interview in
penthouse which I was the first guy ever
put on the cover of penthouse you know
other than Bob Guccione himself I was
the first male on the cover penthouse
and it did great and uh you know and I
came over to to Leno it
that time and he goes whoever thought we
both get to you know where we got to and
I go let me tell you something I know
exactly where I was going maybe you
didn't I go but I'm telling you if I
ever hear you say anything nasty about
me again I go you're a guy stood in
front of that comedy store with the ten
years and bullshitted about vintage cars
and my old Cadillac and then the minute
I made it you wanted to open up your
[ __ ] mouth I go if I come looking for
you again
it's not gonna be any talk involved
believe me just keep your [ __ ] mouth
shut you know and and I never respected
Leno because and it wasn't even me it
was cause his whole reign on The Tonight
Show he never helped other comedians you
know he didn't do what Johnny Carson did
he didn't look to make comics look great
and sit him down and get him deals and
you know when Johnny brought you out if
you'd liked you the next day you got a
deal with the network you know he would
say how great you are these guys wanted
to sit above look down on you okay and
now now let them in on [ __ ] Netflix
looking like a hundred and forty-five
year old Santa Claus what the [ __ ] is
that looks like he's got hay all over
his [ __ ] face just go to your house
and stay in your [ __ ] house nobody
wants to look at you like that
[ __ ] jerk-off [ __ ] guy that's what
I think it I was kind of guys no
seriously like pitch if you're Johnny
Carson if he walked over to me I would
shake in my boots I go so nice to have
met you like whether I was on his show
or not it's it's Johnny Carson who loved
comedy when Don Rickles was on when
rodney was on when any comic came on
Carson he looked at it this is their
moment I'm on every [ __ ] night for
what an hour and a half you know let
them shine not these [ __ ] you know
you know get get them on get them off
you know not how great they are
honestly if Jay Leno walked over and
said get the [ __ ] out of here I'm having
coffee who are you you know no respect
that's what I'd give them because they
don't art it you know you gotta earn
that kind of [ __ ] so now here we are
years
okay and Roseann has a little problem
you know when she was on the [ __ ]
ambien or whatever the [ __ ] it was which
I personally have been on ambien I've
been on it and 1617 years because it
does make you say [ __ ] it does turn you
into characters it does make you eat
every [ __ ] thing in the refrigerator
maybe including a shelf or two you know
that's what Ambu doesn't yeah I had a
neighbor move out when I lived in
Franklin Towers in it I first started
going with with tic-tac tits you know
cuz nobody loves Eleanor more than me I
loved it so much I ignored the tits I
treated those tits like you know how
girls get giant tits put on today that's
how I treated those [ __ ] tick tactics
like like you know she wore a bra like
everybody else but she could take a
shirt off maybe one is hanging out like
it's almost like if the bra could talk
it would be saying something like what's
that job exactly you know I mean but
when I would put those tits in my mouth
I would open my mouth like I'm putting
the [ __ ] watermelon him I'm hang on
guys exactly you know make up feel great
about those [ __ ] kids yeah you know
she's gonna kill me for this anyway
anyway so so I had an apartment of
Franklin towers and you know 5:00 in the
morning - with the characters that I
would become their worlds cross somehow
this colonel from the Marines and Marvin
who was a very streetwise
african-american man I'll say a
politically correct and like the colonel
this is 5:00 in the morning would be
like you are in my army son and you will
do as told
and Marvin would be like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'll go AWOL in
[ __ ] and he would cut because when
you're on ambien and you did this by
like without knowing no you got to
understand when you're on ambien you
ever take it Joey no okay
no surprise somebody gave me one all
right about six months ago and I took it
and I thought I was gonna start saying
racial slurs no to call the people of
North s gonna call the names not this is
what happens if you lay down and take an
ambien you're gonna be out cold in five
minutes but let's say by chance you took
the ambien it was all [ __ ] I forgot to
make this call now the ambien takes
effect so you have four sleep and you're
half awake you know you're just
hallucinating on this [ __ ] thing so
that's what would happen to me so I'm in
the living room five in the more
[ __ ] you don't talk to me like
a [ __ ] maybe you will be putting a
break
do you understand I am a colonel in the
United States Army you know so now the
lady next door would be leaving notes on
the door like I don't know who all good
people are you know but it has to stop I
haven't slept in two months and as I'm
yelling the colonel yelling at Marvin
all of a sudden here comes down or going
she would call them by a Marvin you need
to lay down and go to sleep you have to
go to sleep this is what's going on you
know I put max to sleep that way we've
been talking about like Marvin it yeah I
got a little man you could have got a
school you ain't gonna wind up like me
you know [ __ ] I never had the
opportunity you had and [ __ ] and Max is
12 years old in his bed looking at
Marvin like laughing like my father's
nuts you know so what happened is this
woman moved out you know cousin Marvin
because of Marvin and the current you
know and in a pornography
the actress moved in that uh the whole
apartment with Nikki Sixx started dating
huh at the time it was great better
better for me you know who gives a [ __ ]
about that lady spin I've even sorta
lady that moved out
speaking of Eleanor you and her on your
Instagram has to be like one of the
funniest things well entire world you
know we are meeting with the people want
to make a show out of it now they can't
even believe what what goes on with us
it's really let me just finish this all
right go ahead then we could go back to
uh Eleanor take that did no no I did say
that was Joey honor people be gone a
tech doctor I'm in so much trouble
anyway so what happened but she knows
that you know how I feel about them I
don't know whatever I say now it's gonna
be the point is that's not what sold
Eleanor to me you know what I mean like
when I like to like I didn't even look
at her tits you know what I mean like
you ever see her in a sweatshirt you see
what I mean it was more what he is yeah
not because her Reyes was rounded you
know in a good way you know like like
any girl I go with like tits is an extra
like I don't I don't hunt for if I saw a
girl with the biggest tits in the world
going holy [ __ ] now she walked by me and
she's got no ass I go that girls being
punished by God you know because you
know to have tits like that and a face
like that and no [ __ ] ass that girls
never get married that girl's gonna have
to pay your own rent for the rest of
your [ __ ] life
she's got no [ __ ] ass do you
understand I don't want a [ __ ] emery
board
you understand what I'm saying I don't
want a two-by-four it I'll take a big
fat ass like I don't know like anybody
you know and the tits are extra whatever
you know it evens it out better right
you know what I mean if you it's a pitty
on girls without a fat ass thank God
they could throw an ass in today you
know what I mean yeah but it's probably
easier throat it's him right I'm just
saying if the girls rise tits right no I
understand and she's got no ass look at
me when I'm trying to explain something
you know it's a [ __ ] pity right no
yeah like you get all excited look at
this chick walking towards me and then
it goes it's not [ __ ] ass like I
would look at Joey and go that's no asea
right it discos got to probably work
doing [ __ ] jobs just to pay for a car
and she's probably driving a [ __ ]
Prius which sucks right I mean or men
kupah talk about cause the point I'm
getting at when Roseanne I'm gonna lose
my tranq ative door tranq it tre is that
a word people know what I mean my
thought pattern okay
Rossum was on like an ambien whatever
you know and she lost a job whatever and
when I saw that that really bothered me
because I know Rosa him for 33 years
with friends all these years and I'm
like [ __ ] this you know and I waited for
the right time and we spoke and I said
just come to Vegas I'm gonna bring you
on in Vegas and the minute you came on
standing ovations
okay just the standing aisle coming on
and going off and what's great about
Harry basil is he films everything at
the Laugh Factory so we got it all you
know and that's when I said Roseanne I
said I don't give a [ __ ] I go nobody
ever got behind me okay
all these [ __ ] comics these [ __ ]
[ __ ] in their hearts you know and
I'm not talking about you you know I'm
talking about the generation before you
no no I know you know one nut Belzer you
know and I mean people like that fells
it would be on TV going he shouldn't be
allowed to perform and I'm going he's
filthier than me yeah but I took care of
him a long time ago on the stern show
yeah yeah that was that was and I love
bells did his day I love him you know I
mean I mean he's a you know he did a
great job with SUV whatever you know the
the Lauren order thing you know but I'm
saying why would a guy like that be
going against a guy like me when you're
filthy on stage you know it's one thing
if it was Seinfeld who didn't come up
against me you know because he's smart
and he knows what I would do dice does
the [ __ ] okay you know honestly I've
always you know I've always loved that
crew of Jerry Seinfeld and Larry Miller
and Paul Reiser
like that's a different kind of date
clean a comedy and Seinfeld's the best
of that you know who's gonna be better
than that
I mean he actually thinks about what
he's gonna say on stage that's
unbelievable to me I watch these [ __ ]
guys go on with the [ __ ] it used to be
notepads now it's their iPhone let me go
over yeah just give him a [ __ ] thrill
they're so excited you're up there dude
it to new bits and just [ __ ]
entertain them I want to [ __ ] choke
these guys to death anyway so when I saw
that with Roseanne I said I'm not gonna
be the guy that didn't help you know and
I called her I said we're gonna do a
tour and everybody dumped her you know
her manager her agents everybody so I
called my agent Pete Pappalardo you know
who I'm with you know him and Dennis for
30 years I mean Pete was a 20 year old
when I when when I was with Dennis at
first and he was meant it by Dennis
offer and and now he's like one of the
greatest like I'm with Gersh for like
movies and stuff but for personal
appearance I've always been other than
for like a year or two on and off with
with Dennis offer and Pete Pappalardo
Pete being my major agent right now so I
call up Pete and I go listen I got an
idea you know I go I want to go out with
Roseanne you've got a problem handling
huh like would that be good feel you
know and my agents they don't handle
comics they handle rock stars they have
like you know Motley Crue metallic Billy
Joel who just did what what is he on a
60th show at the garden you know once a
month I mean that's you know that's my
other agent that's Dennis author that's
who used to strategize with me for all
the arenas we did that together you know
so he's handled you know everybody you
know what doesn't Anna pissed the way
that I loved well would you do what Joe
Cocker you know he's handled everybody
it's all rock stars it's amazing but
they probably have you know a quarter of
the rock stars in the world okay so I
call Pete and I go would you
handle rows in you know and he goes done
I don't have a problem with her that's
the difference you know so now we're
going on sale putting a few shows on
sale one is the paramount the paramount
which is which I got a call today go we
pick too small of a [ __ ] place
because it's it's like three quarters
sold out already
no it's on presale it doesn't even go on
sale till tomorrow or Friday so they are
holding some tickets for the general
public we might have their to show to
that you know and the Atlantic City it's
it's hard rock hard rock live which is
it is a small arena which is also just
the tickets are flying already as
pre-sales
so I'm like this is gonna be the biggest
comedy tour you know to hit America in a
long time you know and it's Eleanor of
course
alright so Eleanor listen when you hear
the thing about the Pentek thing I'll
just pay you more money for the shows
because Eleanor will open the shows you
know and then it's Roseanne and myself
and maybe we'll do a little something at
the you know I just love her like what
we were dancing when we did the Las
Vegas thing I put on this like crazy
song and we've started doing like the
you know like the dance whatever the
question yeah
you saw the wine in sorry stars born
you saw the wine that I watched a movie
up to that part and I've seen the movie
so many times and they just be out I
just watched it up to the heart in the
beginning and when you said it it was
coming from DICE you said it's so
naturally and it was the story of dice
you said when the way the Gaga goes in
the back do you tell your friends you
know you know I know a thousand guys who
are better than [ __ ] Sinatra
decked-out Singham I'm gonna [ __ ]
table it's a notch only went on stated
on blue eyes and that [ __ ] shark skin
suit and those well it's used he became
Sinatra that's right and all those other
guys just went to the waist up yeah it
just went nowhere and that's what
you did in your mind yeah will you hit
the stage there's no [ __ ] bad there's
no no para but there's no fairy wing but
yeah I I just love to perform like guys
then and that was actually written in
the script I did that right no no no no
that book that one said it written that
I did but not that when you said it it
was just I was like that's that's a line
the only he could say and only he could
understand because the regular actor how
to say that line he would not understand
what he'd be saying yeah because it's
you know it's organic I you know it's
just organic and it you know I've gone
through 40 how long you doing comedy now
28 yeah I'm doing it 41 40 you know like
you know it's like when I think of like
even the arena days let's say it's like
a different lifetime ago you know like
when when I get on Instagram why don't
why don't you have the black in your
head okay cuz I don't want to be that
you know I hardly where the leathers
anymore I like going on in a t-shirt and
my jeans you know you know cuz I seen
you know I you know I got a little angry
with Sebastian for a while because
forget about dice influenced he was
doing dice on stage and specials and and
I love the guy he opened for me years
ago and I you know I would only have
people open for me that I saw potential
in you know and even back then I'd say
it's too dicey and then three years he
got dicey yeah but then he came back to
himself you know and originally what got
me mad at him was when he was on Marc
Maron talkin and Marc Maron was asking
him about opening for me and you know
asked him to tell some stories which we
have a lot of about hanging with me and
he wouldn't tell any stories he wouldn't
tell anything and I'm like you know what
the [ __ ] is this you know I took you
under my wing so it got me it started
getting me angry and then comics would
get me angrier
going he's like dice light when he's up
there you know with the leather jacket
and but before he did the garden which
he did four nights which is humble
believable you know I do love the guy so
when he went on the Howard Stern Show
and and Stern questioned him about me
he answered stern the the right way so I
wrote a whole thing on Instagram about
how great the guy is and and to him like
I'm with you you know like I I wouldn't
want him to think like I I wasn't behind
him because there have been other comics
now like Bill burr has talked to me
about the influence I was in his life
and how he saw me at [ __ ] Boston not the
Boston Garden and I think the Boston
centrum and Bill's one of the funniest
you know that and he you know he plays
drums and when I was doing the arenas I
would end with the giant drum solo I
would play it too I had like an eight
piece band so I would do the Elvis thing
I would do the Travolta thing doing
greased lightning
I would even do some songs on my I would
do love won't let me wait by Luther
Vandross you know just with a keyboard
player and then I would do soul
sacrifice with the band from Santana and
I'd go into a big drum solo so bill I
saw him he was filming Bill burr
presents which Elinor did a spot-on for
Comedy Central so I went to the taping
and I'm going I want you to play the
drums on stage she goes I won't do it
cuz that's what you did and I good but I
also did arenas and you're doing that
you know so play the drums if you want
to play the drums I said I'll come up
with you one night we'll do a double
drum solo you know but I loved the
influence I brought and I you know when
I was doing the arenas I didn't think
that others were ever gonna do it like
you know if you got to be a certain kind
of performer to be able to entertain
20,000 people I geared myself for that
my whole life you know I didn't study
comics I studied Elvis that's who I
studied Elvis Buddy Rich like the
greatest of the greats so when I made it
I knew how to perform you know and but
but other comics have come a lot
rogon he's doing arenas you know you're
doing big theaters how you know
Chappelle's doing it but I love you know
you know a Kevin Hart is spoken about me
in detail about what I did for him you
know like you know when I'm 30 years old
I'm not thinking about a guy that's you
know you know 2 years old with 10 years
old going I want to be that but that's
who I was watching Elvis do the 68
comeback special when I was 12 you know
going oh I could be that but and I
didn't mean as a singer just the whole
image of that person and that's what I
became and stand-up and now because so
many comics all wearing weather jackets
on stage I'm gone [ __ ] that I'll find
something else you know because I've
always said a trend I don't I don't
follow you know I can't have every other
comic way in a motorcycle jacket onstage
and be going up with the motorcycle
jacket so I went to the t-shirts and
I'll cut them out you know I caught him
a certain way and you know and trust me
it's a it's a lot easier because some of
my leathers weighed like 20 pounds Jesus
how's it all together you got a couple
hundred you know I have although still
yeah I have them all I know now and then
I'll give a leather away like one if I
like somebody I'll give them like
leathers that I wore in concert but not
like the dice rules or the Diceman
cometh or the MTV Veejay I have all of
that stuff yeah you don't get that for
my sons you know you don't keep that
stuff away you know it's funny how
Richard Pryor introduced me to comedy
Dangerfield made me thought about doing
comedy and you pushed me over the edge
you push me that's a cool thing like you
pushed me over the edge it's like I knew
once I saw you you let me know I could
do it you would let me know why you were
shooting you could do this that's you
know would you like to buy a flower for
the lady yeah so I can plant in your ass
huh all that stuff was what I was
thinking so at first I was pissed if
like the first week this [ __ ]
stole my [ __ ] you don't even know me
they stole my [ __ ] right out of my
[ __ ] head what street it's street you
must soul
it was so relatable to me and then I
showed everybody who would listen it was
that type of campaign like anybody who
would listen to my and my in-laws were
from Buffalo Catholic I remember having
my father-in-law in the room with the
door locked
[ __ ] out [ __ ] Howlin it's so crazy
now do you have dates for this special
uh-huh anywhere for this tour yeah well
they go on sale tomorrow
I'm only putting this is what so nuts we
just should have released like 20 dates
but you know they'll be more next week
you know cuz these are just these are
gonna be sold out tomorrow you know and
like I said one of them you know is a
cut-down arena and you know when my
agent called me today he goes the
pre-sales are ridiculous
you know that's exciting news because I
want this to be giant because like I
said I just didn't like you know them
squashing this girl who's entertained
millions of people a whole adult life
and because you know we're living in a
in a world where you just say something
and you lose a career not even do
something you say something and you're
being held accountable you know when
people are getting off of murder you
know they're walking you know but yet
you said something and everybody all and
they shouldn't they shouldn't be on TV
you know so I was like [ __ ] that we're
gonna tour you know you know like you
know and that's why the name is so great
mr. and mrs. America you know and I look
at it like making America laugh again
you know because people you know
mediocre has become the new great my son
Max told me anything he goes like when I
watch these comedy specials I can't give
it up if somebody's great I want to
laugh my boy let me to like I'll be
honest when I watched I'll bring back
Sebastian again and I hope he hears this
because I watched him it was at Radio
City Music Hall was his last special and
I sat there with my son Dylan laughing
like an idiot because now I'm not you
know it's hard to watch
if you pissed off at them and you
haven't talked to him about it you know
so like once once my mind was cleared
and I heard that we spoke to Howard and
it was all great and he even said
something about me in Hollywood Reporter
like a week ago like I'm you know I was
his childhood hero that's a that's the
[ __ ] he should have been saying on Marin
just say it what's the big deal you know
so so we watched him at Radio City and
I'm going hysterical and he was being
himself you know what I mean that's what
I loved he like came back to his voice
like you know what I'm talking about
money on stage you know and I go so I
paid the guy in gay but now you turn on
a comedian and he's doing it exactly
like I'm going what are you an
impersonator that would make me angry
you know and I got every right to get
angry at that but when I see the guy
come back to himself because you know
Fame is a funny place when you start
getting famous and you know about it now
when all of a sudden you could walk
through them all and people [ __ ] know
you or you know you're in a movie
theater and people know can't get a
picture with you it's a funny place to
be you know so everybody goes through
different things when they become you
know famous and how how much fame so I
I'm a guy that I think handled it pretty
good because I never became reclusive
you know I go by myself everywhere I
carry a pipe you know what I mean
I don't need a team of security when I
have a pipe you know when people see the
pipe wrapped around my wrist they go
maybe he doesn't want to take a picture
right now maybe a fight with his chick
right now you know it just doesn't look
like he's a picture-taking guy at this
moment it's got a two-foot pipe with a
leather strap around his wrist so but
I'm saying I I always people you sass me
you actually bring in your own cleaning
and go to the gross okay yeah why
wouldn't I like I never understood that
much when you become reclusive it's the
worst [ __ ] thing because you can't go
back from that you get you know what are
you gonna reteach yourself how to be
amongst people I want to sit at a coffee
I'm gonna sit around all afraid like an
[ __ ]
I remember corn Howard Stern this is
great yeah we went house hunting in law
which you regretted
people always regret hanging with it
they're always thrilled to meet me and
then it gets to the point where they say
things like I'm sorry I ever said a load
of this guy understand you know but the
first time they meet you it's an honor
and then it gets bad you know then it's
the 4:00 in the morning calls you know
what are you doing what do you mean what
am i doing I'm sleeping
you know what would I be doing at the
4:30 a.m. you know I got to get up in an
hour for a shoot you know I go put you
up already you never finish telling me a
story about like one time I called
Daniel Baldwin right and uh I didn't
know he's in New York how the [ __ ] do I
know where he is and uh and it was 5:00
in the morning you know and I go what
are you doing any girls dice I I gotta
get up in an hour
I go yeah but you wrote now you're up
you know so you would tell me the story
how you met the redheaded girl and it
goes can't we do this another time like
oh but you're all right you're not gonna
be able to go to sleep after we talked
you know so we might as well [ __ ] a
half hour and then you could you knows
I'm hanging the phone up dice you know
you'll have to hear about the redhead or
another all right that's up to you but
don't call me back once you can't sleep
don't call me back and I hang up [ __ ]
you tow never call them again
I mean I've seen him since but I won't
for she wants to talk late at night you
got a call make put it but so I go
house-hunting with Howard Stern this is
like around you know I wanted to live on
the East Coast because I couldn't get my
parents to move out here so I wanted to
be around family that was like you know
it was overwhelming to do what I was
doing so he takes me house hunting in
Long Island he gets a real estate agent
and if you know and I'm always filming
with the video camera why are you
filming I go why not
why can't it what are you care well
don't film me well why not you're who
I'm with you know and then if we pull up
to a house that I didn't like the
outside the woman would get out and I go
I'm not going in there you know you guys
can't you just go in and she made the
appointment you know I don't like the
outside so there's no reason to it's a
waste of time I'm lying Zhaan if I go in
all right let me go tell her so he goes
and we do the whole house hunting thing
then at the end of the day he goes let's
get something neat I go yeah let's go to
a diner you know and he go oh no no no
he goes I got this great little Italian
place we go downstairs hello Howard it's
1:00 in the afternoon I don't want to go
to Italian place I want to go to a diner
and have a burger and nobody's gonna
bother us you got to understand this
wasn't the Howard Stern you know that
became big throughout the whole country
you know he was only big really you know
probably New York Philly you know he was
building so I get him to go to a diner
which is empty by the way nobody there
other than the waitress and at the end
yes for both their autographs
it wasn't the cell phones where you got
to stand there now right and then they
go oh it came out blurry could go [ __ ]
yourself I'm not taking another one
that's it I'm leaving so it was just
autographs and then I called him about
an hour later I went to Kings Plaza
shopping center in Brooklyn where I had
an apartment in Brooklyn not even a
house in a brick building okay and I
call him up I go how would you know
where I am right now Rekluse I go I'm in
Kings Plaza buying black jeans for
Nassau Coliseum nobody's bothering me
don't just stay in don't become
reclusive it's it's just not a good
thing if you don't know how to walk out
of your house by yourself you know I
don't like guys like Axl a reclusive
it's like and what good is any of it you
know if you can't just go you know I
just got to get out of God I don't need
a team with me I don't need a bunch of
people looking around
pulling up and [ __ ] SUVs I want a
nice coffee
I want a Slurpee you know I don't need a
team I need my car I need me and I need
the pipe that's it without a team that
you're unnoticed without a team you know
this you walk in you people don't even
know you're gonna see me baby someone
all over the place people don't even
know I throw on a baseball hat yeah
people I've no idea
you know I stand there table I'm losing
hundreds of thousands nobody even
notices
other than the casino beautiful you lost
hundreds of thousands of course don't
you know exactly look at the life I get
to lead that's why I could lose a
hundred grand get on stage you'd never
you'd think I've won a hundred grand Wow
yeah I've got the gambling end of my
life was you know I quit now so I don't
gamble now but yeah I've gone you know
I've lost a half a million at a clip
I've won a half a million at a clip in
minutes
this isn't like how much are you betting
a hand well when when those kind of
plays would happen I'd be playing all
six spots at like ten grand a hand
cheese so let's say you just lost one
hand there's 60,000 yeah you know but
let's say you get a winning hand a
couple black Jack's a couple double
downs you win a hundred thousand in a
minute oh yeah but you don't play with
what you don't have you can have fear
when it comes to gambling because that's
all it is is you're taking a chance so
you got to have brass balls and you got
to be willing to lose not win lose
everything in front of you to win that's
the only way you do win because anybody
playing scared is gonna lose always in
life at anything you know if you go on a
stage and you don't open up you're never
gonna make it
you know if you're afraid of the crowd
you're never gonna make it you know
there were rules of engagement with
everything you know you know same thing
with banging bang into a [ __ ] hard oh
who gives a [ __ ] you know if she can't
take this kind of bang she couldn't be
my chick right you know what I mean with
everything you just do the best you
could with everything that's how I look
at life
and you you're [ __ ] beautiful what a
philosophy uh you know yeah now if these
people want to go is there gonna be a
website for mr. and mrs. America uh it's
on sale it's on sale you could call um
you know who are they live Nixon I don't
know not like nation are my Peter the
Paramount Theater these are yet do you
know in the Hard Rock no exactly there's
gonna be more on sale now because this
is just this is escalating quickly
quicker than I thought about it
absolutely you know Roseanne ready to
rock yeah yeah she we won the phone the
other night all excited she's complete
cuz she did a couple shows already you
know this this month and just on her own
just to get a feet wet and she got
standing O's and you know you know she
loves it like we love it you know and
she's always been a great great comic I
was talking about how you know you know
when years ago when people would heckle
her she's the first girl I ever saw look
at somebody in the crowd and go suck my
[ __ ] dick okay you know and this is a
woman yeah we've had some fun times
together
you know she's great that was one time I
went gambling with Roseanne when I was
doing the dunes like I could do the
dunes Comedy Store Mitzi wouldn't even
believe me till I would show her like
the money or the chips in but you know
we got I got 1,500 a week when I did the
Comedy Store at the dunes hotel this
before my career took off you get a
hundred a set it did 15 sets of the
weight so in between sets I go out when
twenty thirty thousand I would take like
two hundred bucks and just parlay it and
just win and go back to do my next show
and the comics would come to Mitzi
because it's even want to see that she
didn't want you know she want to gender
a thumb that's how she was that's just
you know she loved being the mother of
the comics whatever so she'd tell like
uh you know what whatever comic would
run back down go at the end ice just one
thirty thousand dollars in between no II
didn't know II didn't I come back there
go Mitzi what's this
fake echo of course why would I lie
about when I took 200 hours I just beat
them that's all it's not a big deal
common sense makes you win stupid sense
makes you lose that's it you're either
on your game or off you game but you'd
go how did you do that I go I I don't
even know I just know how to do it crazy
[ __ ] one time with Kennison you're gonna
love this because Devin did he always
had a thing with me because you know it
wasn't a sharp-looking guy and I was
that's the bottom line you know and it
was always the two of us on late at
night at the store and I loved the guy
you know like I was thrilled when he
made it you know but he couldn't handle
my success because I made his success
look like he was a club comic you know
I'm doing two nights at the garden and
he's you know it didn't matter anymore
with him that's what happened so with
the dunes hotel and he's already making
it I'm not I'm doing a while making it
as an actor cuz I was doing the Michael
Mann Show crime story so it was almost
like a showdown in the middle of the
casino and the one thing that's very
real about me on stage and off is my
confidence it's just there so we meet in
the middle of the casino he's coming
from the front door and he was dating
Tamiya Watsuki at the time and I'm with
training we've been dating like I don't
know a year so we meet in the middle of
the casino it's just this faceoff you
know yeah it's like how you doing this
is that you know I'm going great just
did a killer show yeah win some money
here you know because how do you know
you're gonna win I go I always win Sam
at anything I do and go I'll show you I
swear to god this is true
trini if she was sitting is she'd go yet
it's exactly how it came down I go watch
this trick and there's a slot machine
right here let's say okay say take a 10
bucks I go watch this and I put the 10
in you know and I just play for the
whole amount a big machine right
ten thousand dollars
right there and then I go that's what
I'm talking about
I always [ __ ] win and he I thought he
might pass out because the look in his
face was like this isn't a movie like a
setup in a movie where a guy walks over
he puts in one a dollar and wins you
know
well this $10,000 just right there what
you know but the bells going off and the
money falling out I go it's Who I am
you know dice you're a [ __ ] Savage
I like that I'm happy you took the
[ __ ] time this is great I'll always
do your show I always have loved when I
kind of love it I've been sitting here
and all brother you know I love happy
that I followed your lead is Here I am
because of you brother
well I'm you know I talk about you a lot
because I'm really proud of what you're
accomplishing you know and keep building
on you know it just started for you like
about five years ago oh yeah as far as
your bill yeah you know you know and I
hear it all you know cuz Kate opens for
me sometimes so we'll talk about you I
won't know oh I see oh yeah hey I'll
yell it when we're on the road like it
gets to the point then I'll go do you
know anything about the history of
comedy you know like I'll get married
how I go it's Joey
about like I'll tell her like a part of
my history that sounds like unreal I go
just as Joey
all right because he knows it all he
he's he's seen me do this [ __ ] what did
I go what do you think his is an example
I'm playing some club in Arizona and
when Eleanor can't do the gigs I have
Kate to him and I don't wanna I don't
want to bring up money but she told me
like what you charge at the door I go
really
I go I think he should do more you know
I mean it's traveling of course the
country whatever she goes what are you
charge it go at least 50 you know I go
it's a club so they need to make money
to afford me
you know it's 300 seats whatever the
[ __ ] it is and she goes oh no did I
charge in that so I go and I don't even
know what they're charging so a little
while later with the manager at a club I
go and I'm with Kate and I go can you uh
tell me I go cuz I only care like this
is what I'm getting for the weekend I'm
all good with it okay how much you
charging you know at the door because
well um you know the the Golden Circle
75 around the stage and then you know
general admissions 55 you know and she
goes no and the guy goes yeah it's dice
you know so although we say to hug cuz I
know you're close where I go it's Joey's
you know it's my whole history you don't
know anything you know you're too busy
just taking pictures you know what I
mean
you should learn who you opening for it
might be good you know so I yell at her
about that stuff but she's funny as [ __ ]
I stood when we go on a sea Ford [ __ ]
family and the movie didn't pay it so
yeah I know that's what I'm saying see
she doesn't know this stuff she'll like
bring up do you know you were on CNN
with I go yeah what 90 million hits
something like that you know when I
cursed out a guy on CNN fopen in his
mouth some newscaster oh yeah yeah yeah
it's not 90 million but it's millions of
hits that that got and you never heard
from that guy again no oh the one that
you just stopped the interview yeah when
he goes what are you running a gym this
is CNN reporter he you know I'm running
a gym wait [ __ ] you get your information
and that was it once I curse
now I'm gonna destroy the gun but that's
what I'll be honest with all the movies
and all that you know that's all great
and you know I actually get bored on a
movie set I hate the waiting around I
can't take it that Guy'd even come over
to Bradley when we were doing the stars
born that scene you were talking about
with the sing people under the table you
know
Sinatra whatever and I went you want to
get out of here already you know you
know and he's looking at me go what do
you mean get
we're filming a scene and yeah how much
you're gonna film looks to me like you
got it you know what are you gonna film
the toaster now you gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here go for coffee or something
you know it's done like you know how
much you know I know you knew it this
[ __ ] but like how long you want to hang
around here you know it gets really
boring to me you know so the live thing
is you know it's nothing like it
it's just nothing like it clubs are the
absolute greatest to perform in but you
know I'm gonna go into these bigger
places again because this is a bigger
than life show so you have to you know
it's you're still doing it right now and
I applaud you to death
listen if you want to get tickets for
dice and the mr. and mrs. America tour
they go on presale them although no
there aren't around
tomorrow that tomorrow are they they go
on [ __ ] sale open up with the Pamela
theater the Hard Rock Cafe in Atlantic
City and there'll be more dead Hard Rock
Live Hard Rock Live if you need dates if
he tweets about retweet them for you
alright thank you that's it and that's
that the show is brought to you by him
for hims com a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care and sexual wellness for
men men need all the help they could get
now for you young guys you know from
time to time things are slipping but
with age comes wisdom but getting older
can also be a downer especially when you
want to have sex from time to time 40%
of men by the age of 40 struggle with
not being able to get and maintain an
erection that's a goddamn shame here I'd
knocked up my wife at 50 so you guys got
to get it together
why are you gonna turn to weird
solutions that do nothing well you can
turn to medicine and science-y expensive
bill injections
that's no man wants an injection what I
want you to do is there's be wise and
check out for hims like I said it's a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness hims will connect
you with real licensed doctors and
fda-approved pharmacists to treat Eady
they got well-known generic
to name-brand prescriptions to help you
combat erectile dysfunction right
prescription solutions backed by science
and made more affordable to you that's
what forums does see the results were
other treatments fall short stop
worrying about multiple in office doctor
visits no painful injection or any other
treatments it's very easy you answer a
few questions about your medical history
you chat with a doctor for a
confidential review and if you're
approved the products are shipped
directly to your door
nobody knows nothing being your best
means performing at your best it's a
wreck tile without the dysfunction it's
hard made easy so say hello to your new
little friend now what I'm gonna do is
this for the church family a lot of you
guys have this problem you don't want to
go to a doctor forget about all that for
a month we're going to give you hymns
for five hours that's right five hours
you get started for five bucks while
supplies last prescription products are
subject to doctor approval and require
an online consultation with a physician
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate how's that go to the website
for full details and for safety
information this would cost you hundreds
if you went to a doctor or a pharmacy
forget that go to four hems com slash
Church that's four hems dot-com slash
Church and now as a special treat what
we said we're gonna play we're gonna
play
yes both of your son's band no one cares
that's life kick it Lee I'll see you
[ __ ] next week Columbus is sold
out but I'll see you [ __ ] on
the rec room
July 5th and I'll see you in Charlotte
at the comedy zone the 11th through the
13th kick this [ __ ] melee